i invested tens of thousands of dollars  when i was 18 into valiant and image  comics all of which have gone down to  basically zero but had i take spent that  same ten thousand dollars on vintage  x-men and spider-man and superman comics  20 years later i would have done well i  picked the wrong comics i was right  about comics i saw back in 1999 that  nerd culture was going to become  mainstream culture i was right but  instead of buying a bunch of toy biz  invisible women and ice fan figures for  80 90 and 100 bucks it shows i should  have been buying you know transformer  gen one in package and that's what i  think is happening right now with nft  land people are buying the newest mint  the newest mint the newest bad the  newest influencer pump and what you're  looking for is the 4 to 5 to 15 to 75  really good projects i believe the only  way you even have a prayer is to make a  judgment call on the founder